gérard filoche bonsoir alors ce report
du second tour semble désormais
inévitable pour vous qu'est ce qu'il
veut vraiment edouard philippe
parce que si j'ai bien compris au
premier tour edouard philippe hui dans
une situation difficile et il va être
battu au 2e tour probablement s'il y en
a alors est-ce qu'il est intéressé pour
des raisons sanitaires ou pour des
raisons politiques
la question reste un peu ouverte moi je
suis préoccupé d'abord par régions
sanitaires bien sûr mais moi je crois
que le gouvernement devrait mettre 5
milliards sur la table tout de suite
pour les hôpitaux 5 milliards pour
augmenter les salaires des infirmières
des aides soignantes des mets des
médecins qui travaillent trop pour
recruter des effectifs il suffit pas de
dire que on va faire revenir les
infirmières retraitées combien on va les
payer
moi j'ai passé du temps à l'hôpital
hélas pour moi au début du mois de
janvier je voyais les infirmières qui
faisait 12 heures et qui était payé 350
euros
l'hôpital a été cassée depuis deux ans
il ya une grave à l'hôpital depuis un an
jamais macro n'a répondu à cela il n'a
pas entendu madame butin non plus et
maintenant il y parle de pandémie mais
si les hôpitaux peuvent pas faire face à
la pandémie
c'est leur faute et il faut qu'il la
répare tout de suite 5 milliards pour
les hôpitaux parce que l'eau reste les
considérations tacticienne manoeuvrière
électorale ça ça passe après cette
réponse en matière de santé et je vois
pas pourquoi je n'arrive pas à
comprendre la politique de macron ya
quinze jours il y avait un comité de
défense
ils ont pour la première fois posé la
question du report des municipales et au
lieu de parler du report des municipales
il ya quinze jours qu'un jour ils ont
fait le 49-3
je ne comprends pas la cohérence de tout
ça j'ai pas l'impression que ma croûte
pour l'occupant premier de la santé des
français
j'ai plutôt l'impression qu'ils
s'occupent d'eux comment s'en sortir et
sans aucun doute edouard philippe aussi
alors maintenant si toutes les les
autorités disent qu'il faut un
confinement complet il faut un
confinement complet bien sûr mais encore
une fois fois pouvoir faire des tests
j'ai entendu monsieur olivier verrons ce
soir minizoo la santé dit on fait 2000
tests par jour j'ai bien compris 2000
seulement on n'a pas des moyens en
france d'en faire plus est ce que ce
chiffre est vrai pourquoi y at-il pas
immédiatement tout mis sur la table pour
faire plus de tests je sais qu'on peut
pas les faire pour tout le monde on me
dit c'est impossible mais on peut le
faire pour un plus grand nombre de gens
qui sont touchés
on peut dépister un peu plus des kia
pour tout ça me semble
comment vous dire sans queue ni tête du
point de vue de l'accueil rang son plus
haut niveau du pouvoir
c'est ce pouvoir qui va décider de
reporter les élections
sauf que les laboratoires a pris ne sont
pas en mesure d'effectuer allait les
faire à l'hôpital jusqu'à présent gérard
filoche c'est ce que vous êtes d'accord
avec ce qu'a dit marine le pen madame
madame 5,5 milliards allez-y madame à la
re non j'ai pas entendu marine le pen
par les 2,5 milliards pour les pour les
hôpitaux un jeu quand on parle de
questions sociales en général marine le
pen à elle est plus large
moi je suis préoccupé par les questions
sociales je suis préoccupé par les
hospitaliers par les soignants les aides
soignantes les infirmières les
infirmiers les médecins tous ceux qui à
l'hôpital aujourd'hui se trouve compris
à la gorge et pour faut 5 milliards tout
de suite pas dans deux mois pendant
trois mois d'ailleurs macron si c'est
dans trois mois
iman tellement qui ne tiendra pas donc
il lâche tout de suite 5 milliards qu'on
trouve tous les moyens de démultiplier
la cac et le soin ya pas que le
coronavirus on sait bien il ya la grippe
bondé bien personnes sont menacées par
la grippe y ait encore plus de morts à
ce que je sais je suis pas un
scientifique par la grippe plutôt que
par corona virus bon pour traiter tous à
l'hôpital est engorgé et donc c'est
d'abord prendre la question de l'hôpital
la priorité absolue est de dire qu'est
ce qu'on y change
comment on leur donne les moyens
débloquer 5 milliards pour l'hôpital du
coup
filoche au vu d'une abstention très
forte ce soir comment est ce que on peut
voir les résultats de ce premier tour à
ce qu'il faut les maintenir
et puis reporté un second tour comme le
disait marine le pen écoutez moi je
regarde les résultats il ya quand même
pour ce qui est des macros nhien c'est
un effondrement par tous toute façon il
se cachait et les listes il les affiches
est pas leurs couleurs il faisait des
coalitions savait pas trop bon qu'est ce
qui se dégage comme première tendance
s'est pas encore facile à dire mais
enfin si on prend la ville comme le
havre
c'est une poussée pour la gauche unie
les écologistes viennent après ils ont
lit à des réserves de voir et le premier
ministre qui quand même la figure de
proue de la politique menée depuis deux
ans est sur la sellette avec 43% il
passe pas au premier tour comme la
dernière fois il a perdu plus de 10% des
voix et le second tour est presque lui
est fatale moi je vois c'est dans pas
mal de villes c'est dire que la wii est
la gauche unie ça marche
là où il ya une addition de force
politique qui ce qu elle coalisés puis
qui se dépasse là où les parties se
mettent d'accord et son rang dynamique
ça passe me semble-t-il
bon alors après je vois bien le le à
part la disparition de l'est mer la
menace du front national à perpignan et
je pense qu'il faut faire barrage à
monsieur aller au qinghai pas une vie le
plus habile habitants mais la question
c'est l'unité de la gauche il aurait dû
se faire là bas
et quand y'a pas l'unité de la gauche
évidemment il ya des menaces de ce type
alors je vous me demandez est-ce que ça
doit se faire la semaine prochaine
moi ce que je veux pas si vous me
permettez de le dire avec mes mots c'est
que mettront macron gagne du temps parce
que toute une partie de ce qui va mal
enfants c'est à cause de lui et les les
élections là sont en passe de le
sanctionner
alors si vous gagnez du temps et et si
ça ça puis effectivement soit une
nécessité de confinement général pour
des raisons sanitaires
bon ça va s'imposer c'est pas moi qui
décide mais alors justement s'agira-t-il
h
est-ce que c'est qu'on retrouve les
conditions du vote est-ce que juste
le fait de ne pas avoir de second tour
tout en maintenant les résultats du
premier ce que ça ne va pas biaisé
justement les résultats et le deuxième
tour puisque on aura déjà une une
estimation des premiers évidemment
madame éviter les huit matches
évidemment madame c crève coeur le choix
démocratique est plus important là on a
un conflit de comment dirais-je entre le
sanitaire et la démocratie et moi j'aime
les deux les soins sanitaires 5
milliards pour les hôpitaux et j'aime la
démocratie c'est là que les élections se
tiennent régulièrement par exemple je ne
voudrais pas que macron regroupe comme
il voulait au début les élections
municipales territoriales et régionales
parce qu'il avait l'intention de faire
ça vous savez c'était dans ses plans je
sais pas si c'est pas encore dans ses
plans caché dans le fond de sa tête
aujourd'hui avec ce qui se passe mais je
suis pas pour qu'il vienne une élection
groupée dans trois ans donc en vérité si
les élections municipales du deuxième
tour ne peuvent pas pour les raisons
sanitaires de confinement généralisé se
tenir dimanche prochain pour christiane
le plus tôt possible en partant des
résultats du premier je veux pas de
macron puisse échapper à la sanction
le président macron qui d'ailleurs avait
annoncé qui lui ne tirerai aucune leçon
national de ce scrutin est ce que vous y
croyez aujourd'hui à cette parole
broyles a bien tort parce que il ya des
gens il explique que les élections
municipales sont pas politiques mais
sont politiques
tout est politique dans la vie même le
traitement de du confinement et des
décisions salutaires ces politiques et
mâcon et quand il disait je vous
échapper aux municipales mais excusez
moi je vais vous faire un retour en
arrière en 2014
françois hollande avait déjà commencé
une politique si mauvaise mais déjà
tellement commencé à travailler à la
gauche que ça a été un désastre pour le
parti socialiste aux municipales
s'étaient pas à cause des maires c'était
pâques aux conditions locales
c'était parce que les gens cherchaient
le sanctions moi j'avais un cas j'avais
un ami qui était dans une petite ville
de luberon il était élu maire depuis
deux mandats il avait à ce moment-là
perdu 2,21 une voix
comme on se connaît dans une petite
ville et étaient allés voir ce qu'ils
étaient pas venus voter qu'ils s'étaient
abstenus et il lui avait dit oh mais tu
sais philippe c'est pas pour toi nous on
t'aime bien comme maire vous voulez dire
à hollande que ça allait pas alors fini
puis répondre eh bé c'est moi qui était
battu et effectivement ça se passe
toujours comme ça c'est à dire que quand
vous avez des élections régionales aussi
en 2004 rappelez-vous 2003 fillon impose
une erreur la casse des retraites une
première fois et en 2004 la gauche gagne
20 régions sur 22
c'était pas à cause du mérite des
présidents de région
c'était parce que les gens se vengerait
en 2004 sur 20 régions sur 22 ce que la
politique de fillon et de raf raffarin
lors avait fait contre leur retraite
donc il ya toujours un lien entre les
élections locales et les élections
nationales sur ses villages ses
élections municipales maison kitsch oui
gérard que de particuliers les
socialistes tout comme hérétique la vie
des gens lire les socialistes tout comme
les républicains espèrent en tout cas
que ces élections on être pour une
renaissance après les les résultats que
l'on connaît des dernières élections ont
laminé ces deux grands partis principaux
il y à il ya quelques temps vous pensez
que ce sera l'occasion pour eux de
revivre de renaître
mettez pas les républicains et
socialistes ont le même plan parce que
si on prend l'exemple des dépositions de
l'un et l'autre sur les retraites des
républicains sont pour la retraite à 65
ans et maintenant les socialistes je
m'en réjouis ont pris position contre la
retraite par points donc il ne faut pas
mettre sur le même plan ceux qui en
train de se passer dans la vie politique
dans la conscience de millions de gens
c'est d'eux qu'il refuse la casse
sociale de macron il refuse les
retraites qui ne les casse
il refuse la classe du chômage
d'ailleurs ça serait bien que le 1er
avril prochain il soit pas appliqué la
loi sur le chômage qui est passé à part
en vigueur à partir du 1er novembre et
ensuite les gens sont pas content non
plus de la case de la sncf
il se rappelle trop de la casse du code
du travail donc tout ça est en train de
maturer dans les consciences
macron le sait il a ça en face de lui et
c'est plutôt à gauche que la solution
parce que nous on va pas avoir de
résultat ce que je viens de dire en
train dans un débat entre les
républicains et le pen et plus
les mac revient le vrai choix c'est
entre la droite et la gauche y en a pas
d'autre dans ce pays il n'ya pas de
milieu
y a pas de centre et la gauche c'est la
gauche unie et moi je milite pour soi la
gauche unie si le parti socialiste vous
êtes dedans je m'en réjouis
qu'ils viennent pas être hégémoniques
mais qu'ils soient dedans et dans un
certain nombre de cas en france il est
dedans et dans un certain nombre
d'autres cas il est un peu trop
hégémonie c'est pas trop la chose en
main il faudrait une vraie unité comment
dirais-je dialoguer démocratique de la
gauche une majorité qui respecte toutes
ses composantes qui les unit fille et
créer une dynamique pour pouvoir gagner
après les avancées du premier tour au
deuxième tour quelle que soit sa date
merci beaucoup gérard filoche d'avoir
répondu à nos questions sur rt france ce
soir